nous sommes sur le territoire de
wittelsheim à la limite du canton de
wittenheim et qui content de cernay nous
visitons la nouvelle caserne de pompiers
cernay wittelsheim les premiers projets
ont été abordés dès 2012 et 2013
les deux casernes de cernay et de
wittelsheim les pompiers ont fusionné
pour faire un nouveau centre de secours
de cette fois ci un centre de secours
renforcé qu'est le quatrième centre par
importance du département le périmètre
du canton de wittenheim est quasiment
celui du
bassin potassique bassin potassique qui
qui a vu le jour au début du 20e siècle
puisque l'exploitation de la potasse a
commencé dans les années 1920 ce band ce
canton de wittenheim comprend donc neuf
communes et il faudrait rajouter à ces
neuf communes pour compléter le bassin
potassique les communes de kingersheim
fisher et ensisheim au début du 20e
siècle il y avait à peu près quinze
mille habitants dans le bassin
potassique
aujourd'hui il y en a quasiment 65000 et
le canton de wittenheim correspond à à
peu près 70 % de cette population
on est donc passé d'un territoire
essentiellement agricole à un territoire
industrialisés par l'exploitation
minière
cette structure ne servira non seulement
naturellement à couvrir l'ensemble des
risques sur ce territoire
ce vaste territoire mais il y aura aussi
beaucoup de formations au sein de cet
établissement
c'est un des centres départementale lie
à d'autres structures importantes qui
appartiennent au conseil départemental
entre autres les quatre collèges que
nous avons sur ce canton à deux collèges
à wittenheim et deux collèges à
wittelsheim les mines de potasse ont eu
un rôle prépondérant dans le
développement de ces territoires non
seulement économique naturellement vers
l'important beaucoup de richesses à
l'ensemble du département voire de
l'alternance war de notre pays mais a eu
aussi un rôle de développement au niveau
des activités de loisirs et sportives
culturelles très très important et ici
nous nous trouvons devant le centre de
loisirs utiles
c est une émanation de deux mines de
potasse c'est un nouveau sens qui a été
créé il existait au temps mais tout le
monde attend potassiques et nous avons
trois centres de ce type dans l'ensemble
du bassin potassique donc ici on
travaille le fer le bois le verre et
avec un moniteur qui s'occupe de tout ce
qui est droit et trois moniteurs
bénévoles qui s'occupent du ter
la pérennisation de la mémoire minière a
été reprise dans le cadre intercommunal
par l'office du tourisme de mulhouse est
aujourd'hui la visite de cette mémoire
minière peut se faire au travers de la
route de la potasse quatre sites
importants ont été identifiés bien sûr
le lieu original originel de
l'extraction de la potasse la mine
joseph else à wittelsheim où l'on trouve
à la fois une collection géologique et
la salle la salle des pendus originel la
seule qui reste de ce patrimoine
il reste donc nous voyons également la
cité minière de staffelfelden le site
rodolphe géré par l'association du
groupe rodolphe plutôt orienté vers des
techniques la technologie qui était
utilisé par lors de l'exploitation de la
potasse ce site d'ailleurs est une
propriété départementale
et puis la dernière étape c'est l'étape
à wittenheim avec le chef allemand
theodor le mémorial des mineurs qui
reprend le nom des anciens des victimes
de l'exploitation minière et l'église
sainte barbe dans l'équipe dans laquelle
on peut admirer les peintures de georges
duval hier pâture de l'art sacré pâture
que georges les vallières a réalisé
après la mort de son fils au
hartmannswillerkopf le tribut à payer
était lourd puisque pratiquement 800
mineurs sont décédés durant l'extraction
de pratiquement un siècle de potasse
pour les besoins de l'exploitation
minière les minots beaucoup défriché et
la nature à surmonter un lourd tribut à
cette
c'est défrichement qui se faisait
pratiquement sur un territoire qui est
un territoire agricole et où il y en a
entre les pôles des bûcherons qui
exploitait la forêt alors pourquoi avoir
choisi ce lieu le parc du rabat real à
wittenheim
tout simplement parce qu'ils symbolisent
justement cette cette renaissance de la
biodiversité et de l'importance de la
barre de l'environnement aujourd'hui le
territoire depuis longtemps tenu compte
de cet aspect de perte de divers de
biodiversité et dans de nombreux projets
a su reconquérir
lentement mais sûrement cette
biodiversité qui avait disparu
l'écomusée en est un exemple
il a été installé sur une friche est
aujourd'hui près de 4000 espèces ont été
identifiées ce soit de la faune ou de la
flore il faut savoir aussi que le nom
bruche la forêt du nonnenbruch qui bien
sûr s'étend bien au delà de du canton de
wittenheim
cette forêt du nonnenbruch est une forêt
de protection et donc qui est dont la
gestion est assurée dans un cadre très
strict
cette forêt pratiquement 10 par pas
disparu mais beaucoup beaucoup de
surfaces ont été ont été cédés aux mines
pour qu'on dit pour leur exploitation
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup d'espacé on a
la chance est notre principale richesse
dans ce canton
si leur disent pas des vastes espaces
avec une renaturation qui se fait au
quotidien et au chili pour une belle
qualité de vie de l'ensemble de nos
habitants